I say on the one hand, I got less scared of
aging by interviewing successful 85-year-olds,
but another way I grew more tolerant of aging
was growing older myself. There are probably
three to five longitudinal studies that compete
with the Grant Study in length, but what makes
the Grant Study unique is that the men have
given us permission to present their lives
in three dimensions, so that the book is not
only about statistics, but it's about stories.
The book is the history of how the men, and
the science, and its author changed from a
pre-World War II view of the world to the
way we see it in 2012. I'm very different
from who I was when I was a 33-year-old whippersnapper studying middle aged men. And the
men, of course, are no longer the 47-year-olds but are 90. And because the wonderful thing about
getting older is that you get better with
time--not worse--these stories become inspirational.
If you stay healthy, and your genes are right,
being 90 can be a lot of fun.